So one of the biggest issues of our time is
one of the issues where the United States
internationally is no longer really a participant
in the discussion. There are no longer really
at the table thanks to Donald Trump. And that
topic is climate change. The climate crisis.
Now it's not some vague thing in the future.
People are dying from climate change and pollution
related issues right now. Now is when we are
either going to figure it out, uh, or not
figure it out and continue to fall further
and further behind more and more urgently
behind in figuring this out.
It's a national security issue. It's a moral
issue. It's a, a physical issue with regard
to the physical health impact that climate
change has on humans and animals on this planet
and biodiversity of the non animal kind as
well. And Donald Trump has been clear. Climate
change is a hoax created by the Chinese. It's
not a problem. The U S is out of the Paris
climate accords. So other countries have to
take the lead. It's not the u s who's going
to do it. And so now if you want to be at
the forefront of fighting climate change,
you don't go to the u s you go to China, you
go to India and you go to other countries.
And this is becoming a very, a vicious circle.
A sort of self fulfilling or self perpetuating
prophecy. Trump simply didn't go to yesterday's
g seven meeting about the climate.
This was the place to talk about the Amazon
rain forest fires, which by the way, the [inaudible]
said, we're going to throw 20 million at it.
There are movies, as has been pointed out
on Twitter, that have budgets that are more
than five times the amount of money that these
seven countries are saying we will devote
to the Amazon fire issue. This was the meeting
about cutting carbon emissions, about dealing
with the crisis that is now, which is climate
change. Trump just wasn't there. Trump was
later asked, why weren't you at the climate
session? He said, oh, we're having it. In
a little while of reports, tried to explain
to him that it's in the past. It already happened.
Time moves forward. Uh, and Trump didn't seem
to hear him, but he says, we have the cleanest
air and the cleanest water on the planet,
which is of course, both ridiculous and untrue.
Instead of five session, did you make it to
the climbing section? Were there any conclusions
they get before you're going to, in fact,
it's going to be our next section, but we
haven't had a different message that you'd
like to deliver it to. You know, I want clean
air and clean water and we're right now having
the cleanest air and clean this water on the
planet. But that's what I want. I want absolutely
drink air and clean water,
living in a complete fantasy world as usual.
And it was later reported that Trump wasn't
there, but someone from his team was French
president McCrone also said, oh, I did broach
the topic of the fires with Trump and Trump
wants the fires put out. So, okay, there's
that. Now, I hate to admit this because I
want the United States to be part of the climate
change discussion. We're one of the biggest
users of fossil fuels. We have to be part
of the solution, but there's probably way
more progress to be made when Donald Trump
is not participating. Uh, the guy suggested
bombing hurricanes to stop them. The guy thinks
climate change is a hoax created by China.
What can you really add to a discussion about
climate change? And unfortunately, the reality
is that Donald Trump's constituents only make
this more feasible. You've got the people
who just don't understand climate change,
so they don't believe in it.
You've got the partisan hacks who just think
it's a matter of opinion, and liberals are
wrong because they want to be on the other
opposite side of liberals. You've got the
religious nuts who believe God would never
make it possible for humans to hurt the planet.
And then you've got like the business and
industry people who probably believe climate
change and accept the science, but they recognize
that their businesses potentially become less
profitable if we take climate change seriously.
And so you have this perfect constituency
to do nothing about climate change and to
feel good and justified about doing nothing
either because they're owning the libs or
because of God or because of whatever else.
Now I understand why Trump didn't go to the
meeting. I'm more left wondering why Trump
even went to the g seven his big contribution
was bringing Melania who gotten media attention
for kissing Emmanuel Macron for suggesting
Russia be allowed back into the [inaudible],
which we'll talk about a little bit later.
Trump did nothing else. Notable in the positive
sense, right? Why do these Sissy Europeans
keep talking about things like climate and
nuclear weapons in the environment and trade?
What about golf scores and moral lago? Trump
should really just stop going and I hate to
say it because the u s not being a participant
short term is a very, very bad thing, but
my thought is this guy is adding nothing and
he's just embarrassing us. Maybe the next
president can start showing up and actually
participating in more of a productive and
respectable way. I believe that we are actually
at that point were Trump just shouldn't even
go to this stuff. Let me know if you agree.
Disagree with me. I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on twitter@davidpakmanshowandofcoursewearenowontwitchattwitch.tv